hello everybody
and so we are live first thing i want to
say as we go live is
apologies to everybody who uh
who is supporting me i realize that i
put the right date but i didn't put the
right day and so i put wednesday
and then i i put the the 28th and so
sorry about that hopefully not too many
people were here yesterday waiting for
it to happen i imagine you would have
seen that the uh
that the video uh had the date for today
so anyway sorry if some people were um
some people uh were in trouble because
of that um and that's possible because
now i see there's only five people
that are in the chat which is fine we'll
have a lot of fun in the chat if there
aren't too many people there um and so
all right for those who are watching
after as you know people support me
uh subscribe on patreon or on paypal
through my website they uh they they
could be there live and i'm also taking
questions in advance from people who
give it a certain amount
um and then we publish these on the
website afterwards and so
let's see who's in the chat james flames
is there guys check out james flames if
you don't know him he's a great artist
who makes posters i think i mentioned
before david flores there is also a
great artist
and so yeah we got a bunch of people
in in there and so
let's see there's a few questions in the
in the chat let's start with those and
see what happens so plays with bricks
says hi jonathan i'm writing a paper on
the science fiction genre as the place
where apathetic theology has been
displaced at a quick glance you have
do you see any problems with this thesis
i mean
yeah i'm not sure
i'm not sure
what's apophatic about science fiction
it's actually it's usually pretty um
maybe it's apocalyptic in the sense that
it
it tends to try to perceive
patterns in the world and tends to want
to project them into the future in order
to see
the finality of their results let's say
and so
it's interesting because you can
understand
that in a certain manner that's what
apocalypticism is in general it's the
sense that
it's like it's the fullness of the
pattern in its all its fruits you could
say that's what you're seeing in
apocalyptic thinking that's why
apocalypse is revelation it's not just
about the end it's about revelation and
so i think that science fiction is
definitely apocalyptic in the sense that
usually what science fiction does is it
takes a pattern that's there now
let's say uh you know
technology going getting out of control
and then it it makes it extreme and
tries to show all the ramifications of
that at a at a larger level so in that
sense apocalyptic but i know about a
prophetic
jared foy says hi jonathan i r recently
the bbc reported a story about a
researcher who posed that after as a 13
year old girl then gained access to a
virtual strip club in the metaverse what
does this mean symbolically that a child
can easily and legally gain access to
that which by law they are prohibited in
physical reality clearly this technology
is blurring the delineation
of our experience of reality is there
any no egg difference between these two
types of reality
is variation in reality a good way to
understand the difference and
implications of the metaverse and so
uh
so in terms of what you saw you know
it's like
this is the problem of the online world
and this is what i talk about all the
time so on the one hand the online world
permits a kind of chaos and a kind of
access to
to things that are forbidden to
things that are taboo all of these
things are accessible
online and there's a way in which like
you like you're saying you can cross
borders you can
uh you can
do things which you wouldn't wouldn't do
in the normal world but that's also
what's calling for the internet to
become more and more controlling and
more and more and being more and more
related to identity and so you can see
that something like this happened the
very fact that they're talking about it
on bbc
is why do you think they're talking
about it on bbc they're also talking
about it because
there's a hope that that won't happen
which means that there won't be there'll
be
fewer and fewer possibilities for
uh anonymous behavior online because we
have to be careful not to repeat this
that these types of things don't happen
and so
the world the online world is going to
become more and more
extreme between identified you know
fully fully identified by your id by
some biometric measure
to
the opposite which is going to be a kind
of legitimate illegal space of you know
the the dark web or whatever um and so
that's where it's going and so yeah
and so um
so i don't know if there's anything
noetic between the two types of reality
one
the the metaverse
is a reality of more extremes it's a
reality that's on the one hand
disembodied but on the other hand is a
place where all the passions play
themselves out and so it's more like you
have to see it more like an extreme like
a separation
a separation of heaven and earth
actually
all right okay
so let's go into the questions so i'm
going to start with a question for the
website from people who support me on
paypal um so john22 asks and so oh yeah
and as you know
for people who ask questions the
questions are
selected and edited just so that there
aren't too many because sometimes these
would go for way too long and then i'd
be so tired at the end that i was barely
answering so
we usually whittle it down to about 50
questions um and so make sure your
questions are good they're not
repetitive and uh that they're that
they're focused on symbolism so here we
go
so john 22
says hi jonathan in the book of numbers
why do you think god orders that the
tribe of levi not be counted
is there a relationship between this
tribe and the periphery thanks john
uh
it's no it well not periphery it has to
do with i've talked about this before so
there's a sense in which there's the
there's the world and then there's that
which is dedicated above and that which
is let's say
dedicated in the sense of marked for
outside and so
the the
the levites they were marked for god
that is they were holy so they weren't
in the normal space which is why the
levites also didn't have a part of the
land
they were they were spread out across
the nation and i think that that's also
why they're not
accounted for because they're not part
they're they're not totally part of of
israel in the sense of the
in the sense of that which is the
business of israel they are kind of
dedicated up and so they're they're
given up to god um
that's the way to understand it
and so yeah so but you can like i've
talked about this well you shouldn't
account for the you shouldn't account
for that which is on the margin you have
to leave a buffer of chaos on the margin
but you also have to not account for
that which is
let's say it's not it doesn't
participate in the world but when you
sacrifice something if you take a lamb
and then you sacrifice it up to god then
it's that it doesn't no longer
participates in the regular
you know trade of the world it is
dedicated and given up and so that's
what the leave arts i think are for and
why they're not counted this way i think
my way of understanding it
so kelly madden asked what meaning do
the linden tree and lindenwood have for
the christian artists especially in
relation to their pre-christian
symbolism
i don't know i don't even know what the
pre-christian symbolism of the linden
tree is
i've i know more about the symbolism of
like uh hardwoods like oak and things
like that but um
i don't know about the linden tree so
sorry
so in the woods asked jonathan i love
your take on the symbolism of christ's
two-stage healing of the blind man
in mark 8 22 25 most interpretations
suggest a metaphorical take is really so
spiritually blind that he needs to be
healed twice i.e to christ first and
second coming but i'm struck by what the
man sees after the first touch men like
trees walking
it could be that christ didn't fail to
heal him fully with that first touch but
gave him spiritual sight first
so that the man correctly perceives
humans as trees the union of heaven and
earth and are insufficiently rooted yeah
you're i think you've got it right that
is the way that i interpret it it's that
you could say that christ made him have
too high a vision
and so he saw what was above and then
christ let's him helped him see what was
below or how it connects so he basically
just saw the patterns which is a problem
by the way you know we tend to think
that people who who have who see the
patterns are are better but not
necessarily because you we really are we
really do believe that reality is
incarnational if you just see the
pattern that you're not able to see how
they
they are connected in the world then you
know it's like a mathematician it's like
you know these theoretical
mathematicians that live in the patterns
and they can barely tie their shoes it's
like that's you know that's a that's the
problem of living up in the patterns too
much and so that is what i would think
is going on there
so david flores asked what do you think
is happening symbolically with the is it
cake stuff people disguising cake as
real objects food etc
uh i mean
i don't know i don't know
what is the symbolism of the is it cake
i'm trying to see
you know
i have no idea but it does fit into the
whole idea of making
food
you know making cakes that look like
things
just in general right having cakes that
have themes and stuff
i have to think about it i don't really
i don't really
know exactly what that is i mean for
sure like just even without thinking
about symbolism it has something to do
with the the capacity for for memetic
creation it has to do with the surprise
of
of creating a representation of
something else in a way that can trick
you into thinking it's the actual thing
you know i mean the same kind of
the same kind of fascination you would
get from someone who could make a hyper
realist painting or someone
who you know uh something like that and
so i think it has maybe something to do
with that
and so
i'm wondering if there's someone in the
uh in the chat
by the way everybody christ has risen i
should have started with that you know
it's it is the it is the bright week
this week and so it's weird because it
feels like this week was super long the
the pasca was
was amazing at our parish this year i
mean it was just it's like there's a
miracle happening i don't know what to
say
it seems to be happening kind of all
over the orthodox church in america or
at least the people that i know of uh
you know we our church like my parish
for 30 years if they had 20 people on a
sunday it was a miracle like it was just
wow there's 20 people in the church so
it was like this minuscule parish that
was always struggling struggling
struggling it could never pay the bills
they could never do anything uh and uh
it's nuts now this year we had we're
having eight people being received into
the church
uh you know
all through posca and then there's some
there's a last one who will be received
a little a bit after pasca so it's it's
nuts uh and i see pictures online of
people having more catechumen than
they've ever had in their life so it's
just uh it's wonderful so yeah i mean
sort of god for all that you know
and so yeah all right let's keep going
so choose agape says in the book of
genesis are hagar and ishmael link to
eve and kane symbolically
hagar won't look upon the child about to
die while mary the new eve stands at the
foot of the cross
i don't know
i don't know if if the best way to
understand it would be something like
eve and kane
uh but there definitely is a pattern
in the patriarchs about
this because it's not just hagar and
ishmael
you know it's also uh
leia and and um
and esau that that are with the same
pattern there's something about so yeah
there's something about the first sun
there's something about and i think that
i i think people are going to think it's
yeah i'm not saying i agree with these
traditions but i think it's these
stories
that that brought the idea of lilith for
example in terms of the idea that there
would have been another
like wife before eve and so i mean it's
interesting to think that in a way the
idea of even cain and then mary as being
the second
the second one and christ also being the
second one the second adam
um
yeah but christ is also the firstborn
and everything so
yeah there's definitely something there
in your intuition but i'm not sure
totally how to how to capture it
um
there's something about that there's
something about the idea of the second
son in all of the old testament
or you know the youngest son or the
second son
and it it seems to be there in um
in fairy tales and stuff as well it's
like a sense in which the first sun is
kind of supposed to be the dedicated one
to god but it all it's like it never
happens it always ends up being the
second one or you know the last one or
whatever and so
so yeah so there's definitely something
about that which is worth thinking about
it's good to see brad in the chat nice
to see you
so james flames who i mentioned he said
you've talked about eventually leaving
the internet and i've been feeling the
same that it seems like it's coming do
you have any preliminary thoughts on
preparing for something like this
for
i don't know i don't really want to do
it because in a way like a lot of the
stuff i'm doing is online but at some
point
i don't know
so he says like prepping for a fast yeah
maybe something like that i think
we just have to be attended to the signs
and then when
being online
cannot happen without compromise which
is something that could happen and some
people just think maybe it already is
happening
you know that that by being online you
are
implicit you have to implicitly or
explicitly
adhere to something that is that is
against your values then
then that would be the moment yeah
um
leori joji says what is the symbolism of
bodybuilding
it's the symbolism of body it's a
symbolism of uh
of large bodies you know the symbolism
of giants the symbolism of uh trying to
make your body large and so
it has i mean it has it has advantages
which is also which is to become
more powerful you know
but um
yeah but it definitely is and that's why
it's like bodybuilding is often linked
to
it's alpha it's it's linked more to as
appearances than it is also to health
let's say and so there's something about
that
which kind of seems to
um
[Music]
frame the bodybuilder in a certain
category or certain types of behaviors
or certain looks
you know um
yeah
yeah i mean i'm all for i'm all for
for being healthy but i don't know i
mean i met a priest who was a
bodybuilder and he was a great priest
like he was actually wonderful and he he
kind of he kind of lived his
bodybuilding as a way to discipline
himself and everything so i don't think
it's impossible you know it's not
impossible
um
all right all right so eric says hi
jonathan i hope you are well yet another
question in regards to the eda stories
i hope you bear with me in the creation
story after the first giant is killed
and cut to pieces they use the skull to
make the sky they raise up it over the
earth with four corners
under which they put a dwarf namely
southwest east uh yeah southwest
southwest east and north i guess what's
the symbolism of the dwarves here
well they put a they put a dwarf under
each corner
is that what it is
i understand them as patterned from
below but i don't understand their place
there and so you're right that's what it
is they are if you will like the
monsters below or the less than human
that are
below uh you know there's something
about the dwarves that are kind of like
reduced humans and so that's why
that so they kind of symbolize the lower
stuff for and also that you know they're
smiths and you know they they they're
minors and all that kind of imagery that
is related to dwarf that are all
underground um and so i think that's
just what it is it's just like it's
it's it's as if you have
you know you have the earth you have the
heaven reaching the corner and then in
the corner of the earth you'll put
you'll put like a like a support you
could say
um
you know it's like
maybe you could think of it almost like
the titans that are holding up the dome
that are holding up heaven if you think
of atlas for example
it probably has something to do with
that like these monsters on the edge
that you see for example on churches and
everything like gargoyles like i think
that's probably what it has to do with
like something below
the monster on the corner um you know
something that isn't quite human or less
than human
um that's also like a guardian maybe
also the four corners something like
that
i think just visually like just in terms
of the usual kind of idea of sacred
space it seems to make sense
um which is also why for example the
idea that atlas is on the you know is in
the
is in the west and like the pillars of
hercules the the
the uh
is that what they are no i mean atlas
would be holding up the sky in spain or
whatever you know on the in the
or down that side so
yeah so i think that that's it that's my
best understanding of that
so wedge young man says former lord
willing drug addict here
after watching your video on the book of
enoch i started to ask myself where are
the demons in my story of misplaced love
are they the ones that talk to me when
i'm being pulled down how can i better
recognize them so i get rid so then i so
i can be rid of them for good
and so you have to understand the the
the the way the demons that they affect
you is
usually through a
it's like a passion where you can
understand it like uh
you've got these desires and there's a a
pattern of behavior
that that is above it and then when
those connect together
that's when you have
that's when you have these repetitive
kind of behaviors that enslave you
and so that's really the way to
understand it i mean
if you if you're if you've seen you if
you wanted to do something like okay if
you've done something that you don't
want to do
then and i think everybody has
i think that you should be able to
recognize that as that's it like when
you when you know you don't want to do
something but then you find yourself
doing it anyways then you understand
that you're
you know you're you're
you're in another personality there's
something else
ruling over you like there's something
that is kind of manipulating you through
your desire and so that's the best way
to understand it
and uh
usually it's hard to um
you have to see them from far away or
else or else you can't really it's hard
to deal with them when you're in the
when you're in the thralls like when
you're
when you're under the influence of like
this pattern and these desires then it's
like it's almost like it's almost it's
too late you have to kind of be able to
see them from afar so that you stop them
further out on the gate you know
and so
you know whatever like for example like
if you're if you're taking drugs then
you know you
you
when you find you know when you've got
when you've gotten whatever you're gonna
get from your friends or from your
dealer or whatever and you've got it in
your hand and on the table it's like too
late you know you had to you had to be
able to see it
you know from the moment when you
started to think about it for the moment
you started to have the desire for the
moment when you started to make excuses
for yourself uh that you started to tell
yourself you know not so bad you know i
did you know i've had a good week you
know i've been
being a good boy or whatever so i kind
of deserve a little break or whatever it
is that's going on in your mind
that's when you have to see it like way
before
way before it gets to you let's say way
before the claws or
are in your back let's say or you know
in your brain
um
all right j grub ass what is the
symbolism of whodunits or murder mystery
stories generally is there anything
about their emergence which
with
with characters such as sherlock holmes
in the latter half of the 1800s that has
to do with industrialization scientism
what is the symbolism of murder at the
central crime of the genre rather than
another kind of crime
so there's a bunch of stuff there
for sure sherlock holmes
is and the murder mystery in that sense
is definitely part of scientism
and industrialization because
it has to do with debunking a mystery
and so usually in not all the sherlock
holmes but in some of the sherlock
holmes stories you'll you really have an
anti-religious uh strain where it's like
these superstitious people they believe
in in superstitious causes
and we're going to to
show them that with reason
and deduction that you can find the true
causes and so you see that of course
scooby-doo is of course the ultimate um
caricature of that but i think that
scooby-doo stuff is already in sherlock
holmes at the outset
so i think that it has something to do
with that it's related to the idea that
that there's a method like a method of
science and
forensics and all these types of things
that will give you the real answers like
they'll give you the true answers um
and so that's what i think you know
why is murder the essential crime
i mean i think it's because murder is
usually the worst crime that you you
know
killing another human is like though is
one of the worst things that we think a
human can do
um
and we recognize it as something of a
scandal and so i think it it it uh
that's why it's usually murders because
yeah because it's the worst thing that
that you can do it's like cane and able
level type of things um
yeah the figure like the figure of the
the figure of the scientist you know
even in batman you have that image right
it's like the figure of the of the
scientist as the one who solves problems
as the one who finds the the the hidden
solutions and it's not about mystery
it's not about religion it's not about i
mean of course it's it's silly because
religion has very little to do with that
kind of stuff uh but it's like you know
it's a weird um
it's like a weird materialist
superstition or maybe like just a
peasant level superstition of you know
it must be ghost it must be
you know who knows who did it like it's
a
so anyways that's my
that's my take on that
right say a popper
says
by the way hey brad it's good to see you
in there i just want to thank you for
coming along
in a recent conversation with brett
weinstein at the 80-minute mark the
conversation turned towards the question
of higher patterns brett agreed with you
that these higher patterns are not
housed in genes but his answer was that
higher patterns are housed in culture
even in brett's usage culture fed
spiritual immaterial could you be able
to one steal man brett's definition of
culture especially the material location
of culture in his definition is not
purely spiritual immaterial and two
provided your own provide your own
definition as to what culture is and so
i don't maybe i misunderstood brett but
my feeling was that
in brett's argumentation
there really it isn't really clear
for him like what
that is because
he tends to really want to bring
what usually we call culture
to the genes that is he tries to
interpret as much
as culture
by the genes even religion through the
genes so he sees them as emerging from
serving he sees them as serving the
genes
but he has a sense in which
accidentally the genes gave us
consciousness
that this just happened and that in
giving us consciousness
they basically gave us a tool
in order to escape the limited program
of the genes now
that is what i understand of what
brett's saying i'm going to talk to him
again in june we already have a date
june 1st i'm going to talk to him i
don't know how long it's going to take
before it comes out but
this is definitely a place where i'm
going to try to probe it more because to
be honest i i think there's a few links
missing in his interpretation
um and maybe it's because i didn't get
it it's possible and so i'll give him
the benefit of the doubt but
that is the way that i understand his
idea and so
what he means by culture or morality
is
something which is a
a it's a it's a virtue of consciousness
which makes us intelligent and able to
escape
the
the patterns that the genes impose on us
now
like i like
you if you listen to the interview
you'll see that i don't totally
understand what that means like i don't
mean i don't understand what he means
when he says that culture
it's like where like the question you're
asking is right is right exactly right
it's like oh so then where are these
patterns you know
you know if you can
and so even if they're tools they still
have a certain form of existence and
where do they exist like how do they
exist
and i don't think and i don't totally
think that brett's theory accounts for
that but like i said i'm totally i
totally
think that i might be wrong and that i'm
hoping that we can kind of get to that
in the second part
now
my own definition of culture is is
really irrelevant because i i don't
think that's the right way of looking at
it
um
i don't have a definition of culture
what i have
is a fractal relationship between
phenomena and patterns that is there are
patterns and there are there are
possibilities you know potential and
those join together to create things we
recognize as having being
and but all beings are patterned
and
what you would most people would call
culture are just
let's say higher level patterns
which are which affect intelligent
beings that are
you know they are behaviors rituals they
are uh things we celebrate things we
and those none of these are arbitrary
they're all very coherent and they
actually kind of they actually kind of
build up towards you know the difference
between the towards
not higher intelligence is i don't know
how to say it so
so i just don't tend to think
i don't think it's a good idea to have
something like culture which is
completely separate from everything else
i think it's better to see
the pattern fractally because
let me give you an example like
is um
let's say is a dog are two dogs engaging
in a submission ritual
is that culture
and if not why not
right and if so what's the relationship
between that and our own ritual as a
ritualized behaviors that we call
culture
i'm going to answer a little bit of that
because i i recorded a video on
sacrifice which i think is going to be a
little bit of a doozy i recorded a a
video on sacrifice and especially human
sacrifice trying to help uh people
understand how we can get to
to sacrifice and even sacrifice using of
course gerard to a certain extent but
also using other um
like just my theory of
not my theory but the theory that i that
i engage with in terms of fractal
and fractal existence um so anyways look
forward for that i think it's coming out
it's coming it might come out a few days
after this video on online so
so matthew wyden says why does the
stereotypical american drive a big
jacked up truck
is it something like the natural
expression of love for industry and
individuality
yeah that's exactly what it is and so
the thing
cars are a manifestation of
individualism i don't know what to say
you know they they make individualism
possible and they manifest individualism
in the sense that they really are
expressions of you and you know that
because why would you buy a sports car
like why would you buy a tesla why would
you buy you know a car that is
fashionable it's because it's it's a
form of clothing really it's a form of
large clothing that is very powerful
it's like
you know
people don't understand that it's like
you know the fantasy of the mecca the
fantasy of iron man it's like we are we
already participate in that that's what
a car is a car is the same it's just
that in the narrative version of it like
in the in the more condensed version of
it you actually see the personality of
the person in the mecca itself like
right you see the person out of the
person in the the iron man costume it's
like it's a it's a human extension
that's what a car is already
it's just not as mythological as the
let's say the iron man suit but
that's what it is it has to do with
power especially in terms of of uh
america and north america in general has
to do with individual power
and so it's a it's an extension of
individual power
so
i think that that's the best way to to
see that
so desert carpet says elon musk appears
to breathe new life into twitter
this has also given conservatives a more
boost specifically in the area of free
speech
breathe what is this symbolic role that
musk is playing here is he some sort of
techno god is this a small preview of
when he gives life to our ai overlord by
breathing into the nostrils of an
electric powered robot body thanks
jonathan frydew yeah i wouldn't you know
it's like you know i find it funny too
i'm kind of
i'm i'm having my little guilty pleasure
of of uh of enjoying ilamas making the
jokes and all that and so
i have to admit but i think i'm very
suspicious i'm not at all
i don't at all think that you know
elon musk is a technocrat like yamas is
a is a technical
is it also is like a technical utopian
and so matsuri actually sent me a little
note you know saying
you know i don't know if you noticed
that elon musk said we're going to
authenticate all humans
so
there's also that you know
it's like
yeah
so i'm not a big fan of the authenticate
all humans thing you know in terms of of
how everything is moving towards
these digital ideas not a big fan of
that you know especially as it as it
becomes more and more there's more
pressure and becomes more and more
centralized
but uh nonetheless it's some of it's
pretty funny it's funny just because you
know
there are some people
you know there are some people that are
so blind to their blind spot like
they're these massive blind spot in the
mainstream media ecology you could say
and people just don't see it and so it's
just funny to watch
the blind spots become so flagrant like
just so
uh so flagrant that it's it's like you
know it's hilarious it's
but i don't know if it's gonna change
anything in terms of the big picture
because it's it's only going to
accelerate the culture war or whatever
and i'm not saying
it's funny it's like i'm not thinking
everybody should just give in
you know and just kind of bow down to
the to to what was there before but i'm
not it's it's definitely not going to
get any better it's going to get it's
all going to get worse because you know
it's
everybody's in fighting mode and it's
like everybody's celebrating that musk
is coming in and is doing all these
things and people are supposedly are now
they have new followers and everything
and like i get it because
you know social media youtube all these
platforms twitter have been very
frustrating because they do seem to have
been acting one direction politically
and so
but
i would say
stay cautious you know
so dumas says what is the point of
marriage and scripture is viewed with
extreme importance i'm not exactly sure
why and reducing it to having kids
doesn't seem to be even the main aspect
of it and so
you can understand that marriage is is
really an image of
a marriage is an image of of the life of
god like it's an image of how two beings
can become one without
losing their their
independence you know and so the
relation and it's also like returning
back into
unity in in that sense you see that
you know some of the church fathers
sangre of nisa for example says that
the separation of of man into man to to
to to man and woman was not part of the
fall but it was done in foresight of the
fall
in the sense that
there is already like this separation
uh and marriage is how there's this kind
of return to unity through
you know without destroying multiplicity
but it's also because it's an image of
god and the soul it's an image of
how we are all of us are
can become you know the bride of christ
uh and so marriage is a is a way in
which to
fractally experience that and understand
you know what it means for us also to be
joined with that
with god so
so that's the that's the the point of
marriage um
and i and i don't think that kids are
the
are the main aspect of marriage i think
the main aspect of marriage is to be
that image of god and the of the
relationship between god and man but um
children are also a part of it because
that gives fruit right it's like the
the relationship like with if we be
become the bride of christ if we are the
bride of christ and we will not be
fruitless you know we will
we will
be fruitful and so
there's that too
so divide differences
says hi jonathan
do you plan to do additional movie
reviews in the future
i don't fault you if you don't it's not
like you don't have enough on your plate
but i'm curious if you have any movie
interpretations on the horizon
um
i don't know i
i might do a few informally like for a
patron only i'm thinking about doing
that maybe like for example i'm i'm
pretty sure that this month's video
which i need to record like tomorrow i
guess
this is our last minute to do these this
month's video uh is probably going to be
on the spider-man movie because there's
something really interesting about a
kind of spider-man apocalypse that they
were doing and i thought that there are
some interesting hints and interesting
let's say uh
strategies that that that people other
artists could use in terms in terms of
yeah in terms of that so someone says
dune maybe yeah maybe
i felt like dune like maybe i'd wait a
little bit because it felt like the
first dune
like this first doom movie was was it
didn't it didn't like the story was
there but there wasn't that much story
in it like it really is just the
beginning of the story kind of like our
god's dog book too it's like it kind of
brings the story together uh but it
feels like okay i wanna i'd wanna see
the next movie before i
i comment on it probably
all right so matthew says i appreciate
your emphasis and practice of generating
new christian stories and your emphasis
on the church fathers i wonder how those
fit together given the power of
narrative and that christ himself used
story parable all the time i find it
somewhat surprising that so much early
christian writing was so conceptual
propositional like the early apologist
and the narrative toolkit seems to have
remained underutilized why do you
you think this wasn't a major emphasis
in the early church in other words why
wasn't irenaeus
writing lord of the rings
and so
that's because you're not looking in the
right places
the narrative toolkit
appears in the early church
in the hymns and in the
poetry and in
that's where it is and so
you know if you if you go to an orthodox
church you will see that
there's a play inside the narratives
like a typological game that is
happening with inside the different
hymns of the of the church i mean of
course i talk i often talk about saint
from the syrians um
hymns on paradise and how it is kind of
like the summit of that but there are
other
versions of that
there are also certain more legendary
accounts legendary gospels that um kind
of
joined the story and kind of
participated in the story you know a
kind of
let's say
interpretation through midrash or
interpretation through storytelling you
definitely see that
so you've been to an orthodox church and
you've gone to like just now we went
through all these paschal services and
there's some new beautiful beautiful
uh text
of you know
the lamentations of the mother of god
and her exchanging with christ and
asking him to to to to to resurrect and
and then this answer of christ so these
beautiful narrative structures that are
there in that are in the christian
story and everybody understands that
they're not that they're that they're
not you know at the same level as
scripture or whatever but that they
really are this kind of interpretation
through storytelling so it's there it's
just not the same it's just not this not
it's not the fiction that we think of
today i think
i think the idea of writing fiction like
just just writing fiction is is
i would say
although there are traces of that in the
past it's definitely is more of a modern
phenomena
and so
[Music]
you know even ancient let's say ancient
storytellers if you look at greece their
fiction was often let's say a mid rash
too it was like take the story of the
gods and write a new version of the
story of the gods that emphasizes
certain things you know see it from this
point of view right write the story of
prometheus but from the point of view of
prometheus or or you know and so all the
plays that were written at the time of
the of the greeks they had something of
that in them
so the idea of just writing fiction to
write fiction i think is quite modern i
don't think there's anything wrong with
it but it's definitely
i think the the
the way actually that let's say
the ancients did it was probably better
because it was more participative
so
yeah so that's what i think um
so charlie longoria says my
father-in-law asked me why it was palms
that was scattered in front of christ as
he rode into jerusalem
i wasn't sure what to tell him i kind of
took it as just part of the story but
there but
is there any symbolic significance to
the palm branches
i mean there is in the sense that
the palm branches are like little worlds
they really are fractal like palm branch
is is a fractal structure of the of the
tree right so it's a vertical with all
these horizontal like you can imagine
like a bunch of crosses you know like
all these all these levels of reality
um and and the fact that it's like from
a tree
it's also like from above and so there's
something about that which is
that is what is going
uh
under as christ is walking in so there's
the palm leaves
and then there's also the vestments and
so there's something about the structure
of reality in terms of the tree and the
garments like those are what are being
like put under
on the road as christ is walking in so
the two extremes are
are being are being placed
there so that christ can conquer all of
it right what is it that saint paul says
like you know something like he is right
now like ascending and conquering all
these all these principalities right as
as he's as as the church is setting
itself up he's realizing that christ is
you know spiritually conquering all
these patterns you know invisibly at the
time and that the fruits of that will
appear later
and so i think that that's what the
that's what the palm
the palm leaves have to do with
so would that make sense
so stefan golem brown says what is
symbolism of the saints or the relics
being buried beneath the author of the
church
of course this refers to uh to
revelation because the the saints are
under the altar
and they are praying to god from under
the altar and they're saying you know
how long how long
how long before the return you know come
lord jesus right that's what's that's
what's going on and so
i think
it has to do
have to do with the place of holiness in
christianity
it has to do with the difference between
you know that the church is people
you know you can see this in san gregor
nissa when he goes into the dark the
holy darkness into the divine darkness
christ gives them the pattern of the
tabernacle and one of the things that
gregory nietzsche says is like he
interprets so he says like the the
pillars of the tent they are the the
people like they're the people of the
church and you know this part of the
tabernacle they're the priests this part
of the tabernacle or the are the you
know are the different aspects of the
story and so it's like
the body is a people and so there's that
which is that the foundation of our
church
is the
is the
is the holiness you know
the seeds of the the martyrs become like
seed saints become like seeds that are
planted in the world and then they bear
fruit and so they me they rep they
repeat the pattern of christ in the in a
particular place there's that but
there's also something else like there's
also
something deeper and and more difficult
to understand which is
which is how christ transforms death
into glory
and so
like a human body is something that in
the old testament like you know you
shouldn't touch like if you're if you
touch a human body you're impure
like if you you know it makes you impure
but in christianity that does that that
flips or flips in the sense that there's
an
it's there in the old testament too i've
mentioned this a few times where there's
a relationship between death and glory
the the it's there when when in the um
in the proverbs it talks about how the
how the an old person's white hair are
their glory and so it's like that
it's like how death death and glory
share something in common that's what
you see in the crucifixion
and that's what you see in this i think
it really is a flip where the lowest
thing like this body this dead body
becomes the locust of
a holy place
and a kind of promise of the
resurrection like a you know a glimpse
of
something very mysterious so
yeah
all right
so david flores says honey in the lion
carcass
that's right well i've often said that
you know
that samson is like uh
is like a missed
it's like uh you know samson has a lot
of things that point i remember i forget
it i think it was in irenaeus i think
i'm not sure i think it was in irenaeus
where he said something like that where
he says like one of the one of the one
of the prophets that is the closest to
christ that is the closest to what
christ is is samson and i was like man
yeah there's something about that which
is true like it's totally off like in a
sense that samson misses the mark
dramatically but there are some aspects
in his stories which come really close
especially the relationship
the non-dual aspect right the
relationship with the stranger the
capacity of christ to
to save cain the capacity of christ to
save rome to save his own killers right
to save the stranger the ethiopian
eunuch all that kind of stuff this is
what it's related to this stuff to all
this transformation that christianity
brings
uh and the idea of that which is
right that which is breaking apart or
that which is
dead
is
that it can also the you know the thorns
become
the the spiky thorns become rays of
light you know they turn they transform
into rays of light that's
i'm using a lot of analogies to help you
understand but it's this stuff is hard
to understand
and to contain it all in your mind
all right
so michael o'connor says are you sure
things will continue to get worse i have
the sense that it might not
so
i don't know what to tell you man i
don't want to
you know they'll be they'll
okay think about it this way like uh
things might get better in a certain
manner in the sense that
you know
glory also comes out of difficulty you
know it's like difficulty makes some
things shine darkness makes light shine
more it makes you see it more and so in
that sense
you know
you know like in the sense of what's
going on now it's like
because of covid because of
this the breakdown of meaning
around us because people can kind of
feel the nihilism
palpably in terms of
their own passions but also in terms of
the systems of control then
here we are with this like wave of
orthodox catechumen into the church and
so i think that christianity might
actually see
uh
some surprising some surprising fruits
as things become more difficult but
um yeah
all right so jenna ziki says hi jonathan
do you have any practical takeaways of
from symbolic understanding of the
gospel in terms of combating anxiety
christ says that the father knows what
we need and will supply those needs but
sometimes i get anxious about whether he
will supply other things that may not be
strict needs but that are still very
important especially when i look around
and see how other people do not even
have their basic needs met
and so i mean
i think you have the answer to your
question in your question which is that
and it's what christ says it's like you
cannot add a year of your life by
through worry you can't
do any worry anxiety and worry
doesn't do anything like it doesn't it
doesn't help you any in any way
um
because it also doesn't offer you
a solution right and so
for sure i think that
trusting god but also abandoning
being ready for being ready that you
might not have everything that you want
or that you might not have all the
comforts that you
that you maybe think
you need or whatever but then that's
okay like it's okay because
that's not what's most important and i
say that it's like i don't want
things to get taken away from me like
who does i'm not saying that you should
you should be a masochist or anything
like that but
yeah i mean i think that there's no
other solution besides to to kind of
trust god and to do the things that are
given for you to do you know and
you do the things that you can do and
those that you can't you you have to
to give them up like to
to not hold on to them because they'll
devour you and
then there sometimes there really is
nothing you can do about it so
all right so alexander says in the
gospel christ tells the lord to love god
and his neighbor in order to receive
eternal life the lawyer says who is my
neighbor
christ responds with the parable of the
good samaritan and ask
who was his neighbor the lord said the
samaritan and christ responds
go and do likewise christ seems to say
your neighbor is the one who treats
people kindly therefore be kind when
this in practice make
everyone my neighbor
this is a strange story to me because it
doesn't seem to directly answer the
lord's question dude i totally agree
with you i think that you've got the
right i think that you've got the right
insight man that story
that story i don't think i understand
that story for the same reason that
you're saying
because
you would you would say it's like
the way that we in okay the way that we
interpret that parable
is that
the lord says
like when christ is saying is like the
samaritan recognized the jew
as his neighbor
even though he was a stranger to him
and he helped him and those that should
have helped him
you know his own countrymen didn't help
him for this or that reason
and so
you would think
you know who was
who is my neighbor
christ says love your neighbor it's like
your neighbor
you are loving your neighbor when you're
acting like the samaritan right but
that's not what he's saying he says the
opposite which is just difficult i don't
totally understand
because he says
at least at least unless it's not
translated well but at least in every
translation i've seen
he asks like who was the neighbor of the
of the the man who got beaten and the
answer is
the samaritan
who
who helped him
and so is that who you're supposed to
love like those that help you but then
christ in other places says love your
enemy and so
it's very mysterious i agree and
sometimes i feel like maybe there's
something in the the translations that
we're not getting i'm not sure
um
[Music]
yeah
but there's often in with the things
that christ says there's often like a
kind of
things are not what they seem there's
always something a little more that when
people retell the story they don't say
it the way that it really is they kind
of change it a little because
it's a little off-putting sometimes it's
not completely
suckably what you would think it would
be
people do that with the bible all the
time
my favorite one is when people say that
god told no
god told jonah
that to to tell the people of nineveh to
repent and that if they didn't repent
then god would destroy the city and it's
like god never said that god just told
god just told jonah to tell the people
nineveh that he was gonna destroy the
city
he said i'm going to destroy the city
that's what he was supposed to tell them
and then but people put that in there
because they don't like the idea
that god would say to jonah tell them
i'm going to destroy the city and jonah
says
oh i'm not going to do that because you
say you're going to do it but then
you're not going to do it
and then god's like tell them anyways
and then he tells them and then god
doesn't destroy the city and it's like
that's a way more
like it's way more of a puzzle and like
a you know a puzzling situation it's a
lot harder to understand that than to
understand the first part i think this
part this samaritan story is the same
it's just really difficult
and i find it difficult
sorry
all right here we go
reuven corp says hi jonathan could you
elaborate on your past comments in which
you speak about succuby being involved
in the making
or consuming of pornography in what ways
does such a connection manifest and so
i'm already going to talk about that i
mean i guess
and so
so
the the you can understand
so the best way to understand it is that
when you're if you see images like
pornographic images on the screen
uh or in a magazine or whatever
that person who was behind that the
person that was filmed doing that that's
not what you that's not what you're
seeing
you're seeing a whole you're seeing a
whole
nexus of causalities which is making
that image appear in front of you a
whole nexus of wills that is not just to
do with the person being filmed or being
photographed but it has to do with the
people that are organizing it and the
people that are that are putting it
online and the people that are promoting
it and the people that have
all kinds of reasons for that to be
there whether it's to make money or for
whatever other reason and so
by the time that you encounter it
you're not encountering that person
you're encountering a complex network of
patterns
and those patterns have a
reality and that reality is some it is
exactly
what a succubus is supposed to be like
the succubus is there to make you lose
your seed that's the purpose of a
succubus is to steal your seed away from
you
and you can see that in many ways you
can see that in terms of
not produced children you can see that
in this sense of
distract you from your real purposes so
like to take your attention and your
desire away from the things that you
should be attending
uh to and desiring uh and so it will
take you away from your relationships it
will harm your possibility of entering
into a relationship it will
also
um
just in general take up your attention
and your time and in your mind space and
all of that it'll fill up your
imagination and so that's what succuby
are you know
i don't know what to say you know it's
like they are they are invisible
beings that
that are there to take away your
your seat so that's what pornography
does
so i hope that makes sense
i know that a lot of people are not
going to understand what i just said and
they're again going to think like are
going to start saying things like you
know john superstitious or whatever but
the things i'm describing are not
they're completely coherent like if you
can list hear them in the right way
you'll see that
they they make they they make sense as
much from a completely traditional
christian perspective
as much as they make sense from what
purely just anthropological sociological
perspective like they they
they shouldn't surprise anybody
yeah
all right
brad says this is going to be a meme
yeah
man
so alex couch says jordan peterson
described the bible
as the sort of collective dream of
humanity
does this idea have any relation to adam
being put to sleep in genesis 2 in other
words can the rest of the bible from
that point on then be interpreted as
something like the dream of adam
um
i don't think so um
the
adam being put to sleep in genesis 2
[Music]
has more to do with the sabbath
seems that it has to do it's like it's
like a fractal version of the sabbath
um
and it is in a way
you know it i can understand why people
i can understand why the church fathers
see it as something like a prequel
to the fall or something like something
which was done in foresight of the fall
because it's like a little death i guess
like adam goes to sleep he and sleep
sleep in scripture all through scripture
from the old testament the new testament
there's a relationship between scripture
and and and death
and so
yeah
um
in terms of the whole idea of the
collective dream of humanity i mean
i would use a word like maybe
the vision the collective vision of
humanity the word dream i think is
ambiguous because
i mean i think that's probably one of
the place where jordan and i disagree i
think that there are really
different types of dreams and some of
most dreams are not
the bible like most dreams are just
chaos like they're just
a bunch of gibberish and that's why the
father church fathers will tell you to
not pay attention to dreams too much but
i think that once in a while or if you
practice the if you have the right
spiritual practice and on the right
spiritual path then once in a while
dreams can can become like a mirror
for very high patterns they can become
very clear just like you can imagine
that dreams are like going into the
going down into the chaotic waters like
all these waves crashing against each
other you have all these things that are
contradictory that are going all these
different directions that don't make
sense you change bodies you change you
know
every all of it is chaos but then once
in a while that water is like still
and and maybe through prayer through all
kinds of things or through just
providence you have this this
still water and then it becomes a mirror
for
heaven basically and so i think that
that's why
that's why you know the image of you
know the angels speaking to you in a
dream that you find in scripture
you know that joseph uh is has these
angels speaking to him in dreams you
know to go to to go to to go to to
to cut to let's say to to help him
understand that the mother of god is a
virgin and then to go to egypt and all
of that like that's also possible
anyways too much on that all right keep
going
um
all right so dorothea says hi jonathan
could you comment on the whole story of
jairus's daughter
and the woman and the woman who bled for
12 years are intertwined
i guess it has something to do with
menstruation womanhood but i would like
to hear your thoughts and so yeah that
is
that is the insight my friend that is
insight you know i thought about this
recently
uh a few months ago actually
i don't remember why i think it's
because it was the reading in church
and it struck me so much
like it just struck me because it's like
the woman bled for 12 years
jairus's daughter
was i mean i don't even think it says in
the text but it's like yeah 12 years she
was 12 years old and so
it has to do with menstruation it has to
do with
the transition between childhood and
womanhood as
as as a kind of death and resurrection
i don't see any other
i don't think i've ever heard anybody
say that but when you see it together
it's like
it just makes
so much sense that that's what's going
on you know and it and it fits with all
the fairy tales because all the fairy
tales often happen they're all happened
then all those girls that fall asleep
you know snow white and sleeping beauty
and everything they all die when they
enter womanhood and then they have to be
woken up by a prince
um
that's a version of this this is what's
going on in the story it's like it's the
story of snow white
jesus is the prince who's waking up the
princess but now it's like it's at a
different level of course no it's not
it's not just
no it's not just a marriage but it is
really it really has to do with a
fractal
virgin of death which finds itself in
the symbolism of
of menstruation and the moon becoming
dark and then becoming light again like
just that cycle and the death that comes
at the end of the cycle and the residue
which is caused and so in order for the
for the cycle to start again you have to
stop the residue you have to stop the
bleeding and you have to recontain the
body
in a way that restarts the cycle and
that seems to be what christ is
is doing and the man that's like
once again i'm like people are gonna
listen to this i could be like what the
but i i don't see any way around it like
i really don't see any way around that
that's what's going on in that story
um
so hopefully
hopefully i will get into trouble for
that but
all right okay here we go
so rosberg says hi jonathan what is the
symbolism of singleness why does paul
say in 1 corinthians 7 7 it is better to
remain unmarried
as christian singleness best understood
as married to christ or as the married
virgin waiting the bridegroom or both or
is there some other non-marital way of
understanding what paul is talking about
i think that's what it is i think this
is definitely what it is i think it has
to do
with the idea that the the
this has to do with the idea of
sacrifice and has to do with the idea of
self-sacrifice as well
it has to do with the idea that the
highest version of something is
is the man in which it gives itself up
to the higher being and so the the
highest
this the highest form of sexuality
is
is abstinence but not just any kind of
abstinence but you know like dedicated
abstinence you could say abstinence
towards
the higher cause
this fits into just the general pattern
that i talk about which is
you know how elements of something their
highest aspect has to be
the way they participate in the higher
being it has to be right the higher ones
again the highest aspects of all the
elements of this cup has to be how they
give themselves
to
the participating in the cup so in a way
the highest element of any
being it's it's self-negation into a
higher being
that's the highest part of it and so
that seems to be why christian celibacy
uh becomes prominent and why monasticism
becomes the path
let's say the highest path towards god
so you can understand that like the
martyrs for example do that with their
lives that is they give their lives to
christ and they get killed
and then they become the seeds of the
church they become like the
they become the the reason
the image of how everything kind of
comes together how we have to also do
that fractally at lower levels we don't
all have to physically die for christ
but we all have to die for christ to a
certain extent we all have to give away
we have to have to like
to push away our idiosyncrasies and give
the highest parts of ourselves up to to
god whether it's our attention whether
it's our our virtues whether it's
our money like even tithing is part of
this like it all has to do with this
this this capacity for the body to exist
but i and i think that when martyrdom
uh became
less of a question in terms of you know
when rome became christian then then
that other type of giving yourself
became primary the idea that to be
single
is to take
your
sexuality and then you offer it up you
you offer it up to god um and then you
actually become a model
for others so that's why most of our
saints are monks you know and it's like
it's too bad it's annoying people get
annoyed because like why aren't there
more married married science and why you
know it's like i get it but
the there it isn't arbitrary it has to
do with this idea of giving yourself and
sacrifice so the martyrs and then the
ascetics because the ascetics have given
their attention their energy their
sexual energy and they become brides of
christ
it's like a hierarchy right so
and i think the church really does
understand it that way as a hierarchy
because so like for example in the
orthodox church we have married priests
but we don't marry priests
that's the kind of joke that that
orthodox will always make with catholics
it is it's like
they often say that the orthodox have
married priests and so we should we
should be allowed to marry the priest in
the church now it's like no sorry even
if you did take our position once you
become a priest and you're single you're
not allowed to get married and so it's a
hierarchy of giving yourself so if
you're already married and you've given
yourself to your wife then you you it's
like we're not going to get rid of that
then kind of give yourself up but if
you've given yourself up to that highest
then there's no reason to now
engage in those lower versions of it
let's say uh so anyways
hopefully that makes sense
so anton o'landerson says hi jonathan i
hope you are doing well
i want to ask about the correlation
between the book of kings and revelation
the [ __ ] babylon seems like an
inversion of the queen of sheba and her
precious stones
and both chapters mention 666 as it is
the number
of the beasts and the weight of
solomon's gold
that's a really interesting uh
connection that you made there that i
never thought about wow
could the mark be attempting luciferian
utopia which will provide you with
wealth i.e gold crypto or is there any
other symbolic correlation between the
two chapters i'd love to hear your
thoughts on this thanks
so there's definitely a relationship for
sure with
for solomon's gold that comes from
the stranger and that also is all
accounted for and the remainder of the
gold is all accounted for there's
definitely a relationship between all
that
and the idea of the mark of the beast as
being this
this perfect mark that accounts for
everything
uh
that if you don't have that you cannot
buy or sell or trade so there's
definitely a a uh
a relationship between those two
um
yeah so that's what i see now but that's
a good intuition i'll definitely have to
think about it more
that there is a there is an image of the
strange woman in the story but in the
in this in revelation
um
it's a the negative aspect of the
strange woman whereas in the story of
solomon it's more like the the um
asking questions right the queen of
sheba comes with her riches and then
asks
enigmas of solomon and get answers from
from the king and so yeah interesting
mika mueller says what is the symbolism
of the northern lights
i can i
i can only imagine because it's not part
of
most of our own
mythologies like in terms of
like it really is a northern phenomena
and so i don't know if they would have
been no i'm sorry
so sorry i don't know if i it would have
been known by
by let's say the people writing
scriptures and stuff
but it definitely has to do with dancing
light i mean it's like decide this image
of light dancing in the heavens i mean i
can just imagine in a more enchanted
world
you know what it could have been like it
i can imagine being almost like a
language maybe here like hearing seeing
it as music as this this music on in the
heavens
but i don't know i never i never have
thought about what it could mean beyond
that
so david 4 says when is the next
revelation video coming
i've been kind of discouraged of doing
that like i was going to do one of the
mark of the beast and
i've been discouraged for a bunch of
reasons that i think i mentioned along
the way in terms of uh saint pauicios
and some of the warnings i got from
people
who were close to him or close to people
that are close to him
uh and so they kind of threw some cold
cold shower on what i was gonna do i
might still make a video on the women in
in in revelation possibly
in terms of the um
the difference between the [ __ ] and the
mother you know and how those two images
are kind of are brought together in
revelation i might do that i might make
a video on the number of the beast again
but i i i still yeah it's not
i think most of you know what i think i
mean i don't think i've been i've been
kind of hinting at it
for a while now so you know i'm not sure
i even need to make that video or maybe
i should just to have more reads but i
don't know
um
so
ajafka says what is the difference
between a spirit and an intelligence or
the spirit and the logos
um
[Music]
and so
i think that that's
also i think it's it's it's how can i
say this i think it's problematic
because i think we often use them
interchangeably i don't think we don't
think there's people use it
systematically uh but for sure
in in let's say in the idea of the
spirit
the holy spirit and the logos there's
definitely a difference and one has to
do with
the space and the other has to do with
let's say the filling or the the
identities that fill the space and so
there's a need for this distance
you know in order for the logos to kind
of fill that distance
because
why does it why does the logos why would
there be a logos if there isn't the
let's say the the
for a better word to use a kind of
distance
for the logos to to
to exist in you know
i don't know i don't know how to say it
so but in terms of
i think it's often used interchangeably
like especially when when in scripture
when it says you know your body soul and
spirit let's say the way we use the word
spirit i think then it just means spirit
in the sense of noose like in the sense
of the highest part of intelligence so
um
so yeah so i don't think i don't think i
don't think there's a system there it's
better to just understand to see it in
the structure and understand what it is
so marcus david why is buddha so similar
to jesus was jesus the configuration of
christ in the east in what way was
buddha divine
why is so similar to jesus i don't know
is he similar to jesus i mean is buddha
more similar to jesus than other figures
that existed before like is he more
similar to jesus than
to the old testament figures or to other
figures like that i don't know i mean
i think that definitely there there's
definitely some
some truth in in many of the things that
buddha did and many things that buddha
says many of those sayings are obviously
have some truth to them
um
[Music]
and in what way was buddha divine i
don't think
i don't think i mean at least in
buddhism like probably because there's
so many strains of buddhism but i mean i
don't i don't think that
that buddha that people considered
buddha to be divine especially not
you know the buddha and the story like
the the prince that that i think they
they considered him to be fully
liberated and i think like in in
buddhist cosmology my understanding
especially in mahayana uh
buddhism my understanding is that
that there are gods like there are
principalities but that the the and
there are bodhisattvas but that
those bodhisattvas are moving towards
complete liberation so
yeah i don't know if it's my i don't
know if it's my job to like see how this
maps on or that it maps on to the way
that christians understand uh this this
divine hierarchy let's say there's
probably some relation or at least
intuitively there's a relationship
people noticed that there were these
these principalities and that there were
these beings that attained certain
levels of
of uh of transformation so i'm sure it's
not it's not just
i'm sure that there's
i don't think they're pretending like i
think they're talking about things that
that are part of their experience so
yeah as much as i'm gonna say about that
yeah
so emmanuel montiel says hi jonathan
with the significance of the number 70
in scripture
there's 70 others in israel 70 nations
divided under unto the gods the 70
disciples that jesus sent out et cetera
is this this supposed to symbolize the
gradual refilling of god in the world
um
yeah i think there are different i think
there are different numbers of uh
completeness or like a complete
something in scripture
and i think that seven and 70 are part
of that
are part of that or that symbolism um
that's the way that i see it and so the
idea that there are seven days in their
70 nations um
you know and then there's 70 disciples i
think that those have to do with a kind
of complete body you could say that way
a completed cycle or a completed body
that's the best i can do with that
i sometimes struggle a little with
numerical symbolism and that's why i
usually don't go into it too much
because i really like to show
if you notice i really like to show
the the actual coherence of symbolism
and like how it's not arbitrary how
there is you can trace like you can
actually you can actually sometimes you
can show the the causal the the causes
that create the meaning and so in number
symbolism i think that like you can do
it you can often do it with like one two
three four
you know maybe up to eight maybe maybe
up to ten maybe uh but then after that
you know yeah then maybe like you know
ten times like you can kind of see it
but there's some numbers that i think
just become
more difficult at least for me to really
to really
understand how i can explain the
symbolism
in terms of causality so i can see it
sometimes you know through analogies but
it remains a little sometimes remains a
bit arbitrary for me but
maybe it's also because i'm not a
mathematician i don't have that
mathematical thinking
all right
so anders vralstad
asked hi jonathan what is the symbolism
of the skin of christ being whipped and
full of scars maybe he
is in some way removing his garments of
skin before ascending the mountain as
christianity is currently dying globally
can we interpret church scandals as the
same scars
yeah that's an interesting idea i don't
think i've ever thought about it that
way the idea that that there's a manner
in which the whipping of christ is a is
a kind of removal
of the garments of skin i'd have to
think about it it's a it's an
interesting insight something to
definitely that i need to think about it
um
so i don't know about the scars like i
don't know it doesn't scripture at least
doesn't say that he has scars from those
from those uh whips it's definitely
talks about the scars
you know the holes in his hands and the
holes in his side that remain you know
in the resurrected body but i don't
think i've heard or seen anything about
the idea that he has scars so
but for sure the laceration like or the
fact you know the fact of being
uh
being whipped is something to think
about it
so what is the symbolism andrew asked
what is the symbolism of hatred in the
bible such as when christ says if anyone
comes to me and does not hate father and
mother wife and children brother and
sister yes even their own life such a
person cannot be my disciple it seems
hate means separation as opposed to the
union that symbol love symbolizes and so
the one thing you always have to do with
christ is you always have to understand
that christ is often saying things
uh
he's trying to point to something which
is is beyond duality and so often what
he does is he has extreme statements
right so he has
he has extreme statements that push
something so far
that it comes to a breaking point right
but then he'll go the other way
and he'll have another statement which
goes far
almost as far but in the other direction
and so
so christ says this like so he says if
you don't you have to hate everyone like
hate even yourself
and then he says something else which is
you have to love your neighbor love your
enemy give your life for your friend you
have to
you know love your neighbor as yourself
which includes also loving yourself and
loving your neighbor and so what's going
on here
and so
the best way to understand it is it
really has to do with the the
the notion of hierarchy itself which is
that
you have to love things in the proper
place and so you have to love christ
more than anything and so you can
express it in an extreme you could say
you have to love christ to the exclusion
of all things you have to hate
everything and attach yourself only to
christ and there's a sense in which if
you say that it can be true but it's
only true if you say the other side as
well which is you have to love everybody
love the entire world you have to love
all of god's creatures you have to love
your enemy you have to love those that
despise you those that persecute you
right and so
you have to be able to hold those two
statements those two types of statements
together to get to the
manner in which christ is both the very
top of the hierarchy but because he is
that he also fills the entire world with
himself
and so there's no other way to
to see that so
i don't how you can interpret that
properly without the other side as well
or else
yeah or else it just becomes you know
because if we really did that then
just that and not the other one too then
we'd be in we'd be in trouble wouldn't
we
so yeah
but i can understand in a moment like
when he says something like that i can
just imagine the disciples there and he
tells them things like that like there's
some things that jesus says that are so
so extreme you know he's constantly
saying extreme things
that
that whole
section in the gospel of john
when he's talking to the public he's not
even talking to his disciples he's
talking to everybody and he says you
know if you do not eat my blood and and
drink my blood and eat my flesh then you
cannot enter into the kingdom or
whatever it's like he's saying that to
people in the street man that's nuts
so yeah yeah man yeah christ
you're gonna i always say you can really
understand why the disciple didn't
totally get what christ was doing until
it was all finished and until the holy
spirit came down and and illuminated for
them all these disparate points and
gathered them together so they could see
the whole pattern they could see how
christ was connected to the old
testament they could see these extreme
statements that christ was making and
how they connected together mysteriously
in this higher version it's like i can i
get it because if you're really honest
when you read scripture
like if you step if you separate the
things from each other man there's some
crazy stuff in there
all right sorry
all right so why lauren says if christ
fills a hierarchy can this also be
understood as establishing or cementing
the hierarchy does the antichrist invert
empty or flatten the hierarchy
so the way that i try to say it is that
the
the antichrist figure
wants to flatten or at least says he
wants to flatten the hierarchy
he says that he wants to make equality
he wants to make all things equal
and
so but the way that he does it is by
opposing
the hierarchy itself
and and
but things aren't equal
they just aren't nothing is equal like
all things are things are always unequal
like even the grass grows unequal like
there's no there's no equality you know
and so in order to
in order to bring about equality the
what what the antichrist figure ends up
having to do
is to
actually create an upside down hierarchy
right and so you can see it it's like
you can't you can't just say
that man that you can't just say that
women are as strong as men you
ultimately have to say something
completely insane like women are
stronger
you can't say that women are as strong
as men you end up having to say
something like
women are stronger than men
and so you can it's like you can't even
you can't even say end up saying
something like
just saying something like trans women
are women you can't say just that you
have to make the trans woman the woman
of the year
you see you see what i'm saying
and it's just like it's just a process
because but in order to equalize when
things aren't equal and things are
actually different and at all different
levels
you have to over emphasize your point to
to a degree that you end up creating
an upside down hierarchy
so that's the way you do it now what's
interesting is that christ also
to a certain extent
flattens the hierarchy but in a the
opposite way
which is that in being at the very top
of the hierarchy
he calls you his friend
from the top he's he has compassion for
those in the hierarchy below him he has
so much compassion that he calls them
into himself and calls them into
into his body and calls calls them his
friends and his brothers and and so it's
a it's like it really is the opposite uh
whereas the the antichrist does it like
this does it like you know we're going
to take this down we're going to
equalize everything and then what ends
up happening is they they they create
you know
a tyranny of the proletariat
you can't just have equality even marx
knew that you have to create a tyranny
of the proletariat in order to get your
thing to happen
you know of course
in the discourse like marx will say
something like you know oh then that
tyranny of the proteroid will dissolve
you know it's like yeah that's [ __ ]
it's like he's not good it's not going
to dissolve once you set up an upside
down hierarchy it's not going to want to
go it's going to end up going on its own
but it's
it's going to then it's going to
reinstate a normal natural you know uh
like hierarchy of things so
yeah all right
all right curacao and curacao says saint
brigid seems to be a good example
of being innocent as a dove and wise as
a serpent saint christopher has a
special relationship
to crossing water but she seems to have
a special relationship to holding fire
what can the western edge learn from her
about her eschatological relationship to
babylon and the embodiment of the bride
and so i have to be honest with you and
it's funny that i don't know who cures
her and cures her i'm actually
suspicious right now but i actually have
a commission for saint brigid right now
and so it's right like i think it's like
this two second or third next icon that
i have to work on and so i haven't yet
mastered st bridget she's someone i
don't know much about but i'm definitely
going to be studying her
you know next week and i'm gonna make a
drawing of her and so i'll be kind of
diving into her life and hopefully i'll
have a better answer for you because
until now i don't know much about her uh
but i have but but the person that
commissioned it sent me
you know a bunch of links and things
that can help me to kind of study her
life and i definitely will be doing that
before i make an icon of her
all right so brandon burns in the chat
says we have to love the entire world
have you met the world i agree but i
mean jesus did so i don't know what to
tell you
it doesn't mean you have to accept
everything loving something doesn't
someone doesn't mean you have to
you have to agree with everything that
they're doing it's that's a different
stance you know
um
so
right so ron wood asks it's awesome to
see some japanese symbolism manifest on
the channel in relation to the grail and
storytelling as garments to skin i'm
curious about the grim stories
they were published most post 18th
century then 100 years later japanese
stories of old were compiled in the
legend of tono much in the same way what
is the symbolism of the grim brothers
compilation of stories being published
as they were
is it in relation to the grail could
this help understand the legend of tono
in a similar way
uh it's definitely
it's not a good sign when you write down
fairy tales all i can tell you i mean in
the sense that it has to do with with
solidification it has to do with a
moving
you know
writing them down gives them
removes some of their magic you could
say
but also but also helps to preserve them
in a moment in a moment where they are
in danger of disappearing so that's kind
of the
writing down these types of stories is a
gamble it's like it's a gamble it's not
a gamble it's like a it's a double-edged
sword you know
um so i think that that's what's going
on i think that in the age of
rationalism
the world of fairy tales was kind of
ending let's say the the world where
fairy tales ruled was ending and as it
was ending there was a need to
write it down it's the same with dante
by the way you know dante appears at the
at the transition between it between two
ages you know between the middle ages
and what's going to be
the modern world ultimately and so
that's why his com comedia is inscribed
at the time that it is
because it was going away also um
so yeah we you know we're grateful that
they are but it's it's it's also us and
so it's like um
i've said this before it's like the fact
that i'm explaining symbolism to you
guys is not a good sign it's not it's a
bad sign it's just it's a sign that
i mean maybe it'll i don't know like
it's a sign that that that we are so far
from symbolism that we have to have it
explained to us or else or else we don't
it's like it's it's feels out of reach
um and so
but it's also a way to preserve it and
it's a way to also spark
something of that which is which is left
of that like to re-spark something and i
think it's the same with the fairy tales
writing them down is a way to preserve
them to get to game to game to keep some
spark in these in the kind of dying
embers you could say um
so it's it's it's the type of thing that
is inevitable
all right so luca iramaza says what's
the symbolism of flowers why do we
decorate churches so much with it
um
and so
i think flowers definitely have
something to do with glory they have
something to do with like the glory of
plants because they're not fruit yet at
least
like you can you most flowers you can't
eat
they they don't yet participate in the
productive part of the of the world like
they're not an apple they're a flower
which is something which kind of
precedes the fruit and is beautiful and
glorious and attractive
and so i think it has something to do
with that
you know and yeah
but i it would definitely be worth
thinking a little more about why we
why we offer flowers for the dead
and why we decorate churches with
flowers for certain feasts
definitely something to think about and
i i have to admit to you that i haven't
thought about it enough to be able to
say something coherent about that
so daniel townhead asked thoughts on bob
dylan's work both christian and
non-christian
i don't know
if you were gonna i've not never been a
huge fan of bob dylan
uh
yeah
i just never been a big fan of bob dylan
i don't know why
so i don't have much to say i don't
really know much of his songs
all right christian clyde says christ is
risen
truly is risen any thoughts in the
johnny depp court case with his ex-wife
guys you're a celebrity gossiping here
oh man okay so there's something going
on okay so maybe we can say that there's
definitely something going on and and
okay so
there's something going on like there's
something about
elon musk buying twitter
and johnny k and and uh johnny depp
and the the court case
and will smith and the slab all of these
seem to be related there's something
about the there's something about the
cultural moment which is
which is being tested or changing or
um
because
you could say but i don't know totally
what it is like is it the end of me too
is it like the
i don't know i don't know
i'm still watching i'm definitely
watching and thinking and and uh and
you know but it has something to do
i don't know
there's a lot of stuff boiling like
there's a lot of stuff boiling and and
with the with the war in ukraine there's
there's
there's a lot of stuff that's boiling
and i don't totally understand it which
is why
i haven't been super
vocal about some of these things because
it's like i see dimly i don't see
clearly
so sorry
so silas allen says do you have any
insight on the symbolism of child abuse
i mean i think
i think the best way to understand the
symbolism of child abuse is
in some ways to understand it as
one of the worst things that
can happen
that is
in the sense that
as
adults
and as parents especially
in relationship to children we are in a
position that is
an analogical to the position of god
with us with his children that we are
and so there's a sense that if we betray
that analogy
and
an adult abuses a child especially like
a parent abuses their their child or
something like that
that i think it's one of the worst and
it's related to the symbolism of christ
saying you know
you know if you make one of the least of
these like if you what you do to the
least of these that if you if you
if you make if you if one of the these
small these smaller sheep if you make
them go straight like if you make them
as someone who is higher up or an
authority like if you
if you participate in that man there's
not a lot
you're in trouble like you're in serious
trouble so
yeah that's what i think of that
so andre b says it's a bit
counterintuitive for me that jesus was
the logos didn't use words
truthful speech to defend himself at the
trial can you help me clarify this
so maybe i can help you understand it
this way and so
the best way to understand it is to
understand that we are justified from
above
that
self-justification
is the wrong causality
now i'm not saying that you should never
you know you should never justify suffer
whatever but if you understand it like
narratively in terms of
thinking of adam and eve in the garden
you know when
when adam and eve get caught in the
garden what do they do they immediately
blame the other and justify themselves
and they are wrong to do so and the the
blaming others and justifying yourself
is related to the fall itself it's
related to
to pride and wanting to take that
for yourself wanting to self exist self
name self justify
and
what christ is demonstrating is that
even in the darkest moment
like even in the moment where he's
completely right where every he's
completely right that you know there's
no
he has not done nothing wrong
he nonetheless understands that he will
not justify himself
you know that he will be justified by
the father that he will receive his
authority from the father that he will
be he'll be he will be made
right
by the father
um
and so i think that that's the best way
to understand that
and it is you really have to see it
as
healing or or flipping
the self-justification
which leads to death in
the fall
which is now
a refusal to self-justify
and to wait for the father to justify
you even though you're innocent
which ultimately also leads him
surprisingly also like leads him also to
death but then ultimately to
resurrection because as if he he crashes
the whole i'm telling you jesus always
crashes the system he just crashes the
whole thing takes it all smashes it
smashes it together and so he's kind of
doing two opposites at the same time
he's doing something kind of upside down
but right side up and upside down right
side up and you're not even sure like
how much it's all kind of coming
together into this one place
and so that's what i see there
all right chandler turner says
hello jonathan what advice you have for
newlyweds
my fiance and i are getting married in
may we have been together for a long
time and i partially credit the
influence of you and jordan for my
decision to finally stand up and propose
so thank you
and so that's wonderful glory to god i'm
happy to hear that you're getting
married i mean do i what advice do i
have for newlyweds
uh i mean
take it like
take it seriously spend time together
you know
um
spend time together you know
i don't know what else to say
and uh love god love each other
it's tough like it depends on marriages
like some marriages
it just depends on what happens in your
marriage too like some marriages
marriage does something i don't to tell
you marriage does something
uh even if even for people who've been
living together or whatever that or
they've been going out with each other
for very long time promising making an
actual a moment where you crystallize a
promise
it does something so
get ready for that like sometimes it's
great sometimes it's wonderful and then
it's like you know you're carried into
to heaven for a certain amount of time
sometimes years it depends on people
sometimes it does the opposite sometimes
it brings you
into
a very it makes things all of a sudden
becomes very very difficult
you know and you see that with all kinds
of ritual transitions you know
there's a
there's a reality about even when
it's like the first time i say this but
people who've gone through it will know
like there's a reality about being
received let's say being baptized in the
in the orthodox church or being received
in the orthodox church is that you're
gonna have something like that happen to
you for some people they'll like fly to
the moon they'll be like on the moon for
for months or who knows how long and
then for other people it's like as soon
as they get baptized they become like
they are attacked like they just
they are just like
everything seems to want to destroy them
you know after they they get baptized
and sorry i don't want to scare you but
i know that in in marriage
uh
that both of those can happen so you
know but ultimately it's for the best
like he you know i'll be honest with you
guys like our marriage my wife and i it
was really difficult at the outset for
some reason like
just everything was just like
and it lasted for a few years you know
where it was just really tough and you
know i think if we hadn't been christian
we probably would have
uh
divorced but
you know we kind of stuck
we stuck together and we kind of put in
the effort and we put in the
got through the dry spells and the
difficult times and
you know we've been married 23
years now and it's better than it's ever
been you know so
you always have to understand that like
whatever suffering you're going through
now isn't that's not it like your life
isn't over you know things
change so
so anyways
all the best i uh
i wish you the best in your in your in
your marriage
all right so
let's see last questions nate barker
asked hey jonathan what was magic to
ancient people
and what is it in what is it symbolic
meaning was it always demonic or were
there types that were acceptable to
israelites ancient christians
so i think the best way to understand
magic is really just about
action action in the world that it's
like affecting the world things you do
to affect the world
um and so that's just that's usually the
way that i understand it so there's some
magic like technology in a way is magic
i think i even wrote that on
online once i wrote uh
technology is just misunderstood magic
it's like the opposite of the way people
tend to think of it that is
magic is the higher
causes or the let's say the the the
deeper pattern of that's affecting
reality and it contains
all the spiritual elements of it right
that say um
i i use the image of the car before
which is that you know the car is
magical like the car is magic and it and
the spell
happens like it ran itself through
culture
and it beyond the technical
reality of the car it
transformed the very nature of society
like a spell like you know like a spell
it's not it didn't just technically
change things it transformed the very
nature of our relationships to each
other it transformed the way we lived
together all of this was transformed by
something like the car so there is a
magical aspect to the car and so so i
think that's the way that i kind of
understand it now
the idea of demonic magic has to do with
if you watch my video in the book of
enoch you can kind of see it has to do
with
the manner in which
you can
let's say invoke
you can invoke certain things in order
to
gain the power that it offers you and so
that's not that's the that's definitely
the bad kind of magic you know
um
so anyway but you have to understand
that when i say use the word magic i
really mean
in terms of
just affecting doing things to affect
the world and so you know
you could say
like for example like if you could say
that if you learn to hypnotize people
that's a form of magic like if if you
learn to
seduce people that's a form of magic
like if you learn to
so it's all it's all about learning
behaviors and and ritualize ways of
being that will have power on the world
but but technology is also part of that
as well
so
but i mean usually like the kind of
magic that we think of magic like you
know drawing a circle on the ground and
and you know like you know we're doing
that kind of stuff it's like that
usually is stuff you should stay away
from because it it usually does involve
some kind of weird invocation or or some
kind of transaction
you know and all that stuff is probably
best to just really stay away from that
stuff
so uh yeah
all right
so i think we're done man usually lasts
longer than this maybe it's because
there's not that many people in the chat
so i don't know if there are other
questions in the chat i could answer a
few
if you guys want
let's see well if not then we'll go and
that'll be fine for me because i'm tired
so uh all right everybody it's good to
see everybody thanks for brad
for showing up and uh moderating as
usual thanks for everybody
and we'll see you
we'll see you next month so
bye bye